[موسيقى]
نحن نعلم ان القاعده استاذنا الفاضل لدى
هذه التنظيمات انهم يتواجدون في بيئه
التوتر في بيئه الفوضى وان لم توجد هذه
البيئه هم يصنعون بيئه التوتر لا وجود لهم
الا في بيئه التوتر
[موسيقى]
بعض الصفحات التي تناولت هذه الحرب في
بدايتها اولا من ناحيه السعاده والفرح
باندلاع هذه الحرب وثانيا
بالاستنادا الى ما قاله ايمن الظواهري في
احد اصداراته بانه يجوز
المشاركه مع الكفار في حرب الكفار الاخرين
طالما ان ذلك ينهك الكافرين يعني يعني هذا
معنى كلام ايمن الظواهري في حديث سابق له
[موسيقى]
العمل لدى هذه التنظيمات يسبق التنظيرات
الفكريه يعني انهم يقومون بالاعمال ثم
يبحثون عن الدليل الشرعي الذي يستندون
اليه شرعيا وفكريا يعني ليست الفكره سابقه
ابدا العمل ومن ثم هم
توقعت انهم سوف يستغلون هذه الحرب بدايه
لسابق تاريخهم في حرب عام 2014
[موسيقى]